heyyyyyy and welcome to this free course
on the CSS grid layout module CSS grid
is actually a whole new way of creating
website layouts
it'll give you more flexibility than any
other layout system or framework and
it's also pretty intuitive to learn
before we jump into the course I want to
point out that what you see in front of
you now is not a normal video it's an
interactive scrim but screencast and
that means that you as the viewer at any
given time can jump into the code and
change it you can for example head over
to the index dot CSS and change the
color value for the h1 tag let's say
black let's see how your changes
affected the output in the simulator
window here so feel free to do this
whenever you feel the need for
experimenting with the code so that you
make sure that you properly understand
what we're going through okay so why do
you want to learn about CSS grid well
first of all because it makes your life
a whole lot easier when it comes to
creating two-dimensional layouts which
basically almost all websites come
system secondly as you'll see it'll make
your markup significantly simpler it'll
also will give you a lot more
flexibility when it comes to changing
the layouts for example through
responsiveness and it'll also enable you
to actually skip frameworks like for
example bootstrap and finally CSS grid
is now supported by all the major
browsers and the support amongst global
website traffic is climbing quickly to
learn exactly how many percent at the
time you're watching this screencast
check out this URL here now let's kick
off the course by looking at the
benefits CSS grid has over a framework
like bootstrap here we have created two
mock-ups for a website this one is done
using the CSS grid and this one down
here is done using bootstrap the layout
contains a header a menu content and
footer the mark-up is found in the
examples dot HTML here you can see the
HTML for the bootstrap example
here we have the HTML for the grid
example and we can instantly see that
the CSS grid markup is significantly
simpler than the bootstrap markup
because God are all the unnecessary row
items and the ugly class names so as I
mentioned CSS grid will make your markup
cleaner benefit which of course would
become much more apparent if we were to
turn these two examples into full-blown
websites however this of course doesn't
tell the whole story as the grid example
of course needs CSS which you can see
here in the examples dot CSS here is the
CSS needed to create our grid example
conceptually what's happening here is
that instead of trying to define the
layout which is the columns and the rows
in the HTML we're rather defining
everything in the CSS and this brings us
to our next benefit which is that this
separation gives you a lot more
flexibility let's say that you for
example want the menu here to pair up
besides the header when it's being
viewed on mobile to make this happen in
our CSS grid example we simply create a
media query and then we target the items
which we want to change according to the
new layout which is the header the menu
and the content and then simply give
these their new values and the result is
that when we shrink the page and if you
look at this CSS great example you can
see that boom there the menu item jumped
up to the top row the header moves all
the way to the right and the content
took up the entire second row we can
change back boom like that
now if we were to try this in bootstrap
we'd quickly realize the downside of
having the layout defined in the HTML
because what you want to do here is to
make this menu item jump up to the first
row up here however that's not trivial
because the menu item is already trapped
in the second row down here and in order
to move it up to the first row you
actually have to change our markup you
have to cut away this element down here
and a stirring up here that's not
something you can do based upon a simple
media query in CSS you can of course do
it in JavaScript but that's hacky and
more complex so what you want to do
instead is learn CSS grid and I'm gonna
teach you that in this course so just
sit tight and we'll start the next
lecture right away
Hey in this screencast you're going to
learn how to create grids through
defining its rows and columns Grint
consists of two main elements
there's the container which we have here
and then there's the items which are the
elements inside the container in our
case six divs which display the numbers
from 1 to 6 now without any grid layout
this results in 6 divs stacked on top of
each other I've also given them a little
bit of styling but that is nothing to do
with the grid layout itself to turn this
container into a grid we're going to
target it and give it this play um
grid run the code now won't result in
any layout change yet because we haven't
defined how we want our grid to look
like so by default it only has one
column and thereby it looks like we've
just stacked six lives on top of each
other in order to specify the columns
will give the container a grid template
columns will define how many columns and
how wide we want them to be let's set
the first one to a hundred pixels the
second one to auto and the third one 200
pixels as well auto in this case means
that the column will take up whatever
remaining space there is in the width
let's also give the grid a couple of
rows with template grows and let's give
both of them a height of 50 pixels so in
the grid template columns property you
define the width of the columns and in
the grid template rows you define the
height of the rows and as you can see we
have a nice little grid hair as expected
it contains three columns going from top
to bottom one two three and two rows
going from left to right one two since
the second column here is set to auto
this grid is also responsive in order to
make the grid look a little bit nicer I
want to give it a grid gas property and
set it to 3 pixels as you can see that
gives a nice little gap between the
items now let's say we don't want our
grids to be three columns wide and two
rows long
rather two columns wide and three rolls
long then we simply need to remove a
column we can remove this last one here
for example and add a row 200 pixels
down here we run the code you can see
that we have a completely different grid
2 columns 1 2 and 3 rows 1 2 3 the queue
first rows are 50 pixels tall however
the third one is 200 pixels and the grid
is still responsive as the second column
is set to auto so in the next screencast
I'm going to show you a few more ways of
setting these values inside the template
columns and grid template rows but
before we jump on to do that I would
recommend you to jump into the cold hair
and play around with the values so that
you're 100% sure that you understand the
relation between what's going on here in
the CSS and how that plays out in the
simulator over here so go ahead and do
that
and I'll see you in the next screencast
hey there in this screencast I'm going
to teach you a better and more powerful
way of defining columns and rows as you
can see we're now working in the index
dot CSS file and not directly in the
HTML file that's because doing it in the
index dot CSS gives us the benefits of
automatic updates in the browser window
so we have this very simple grid here
which you probably recognize from the
previous cost it's got three columns the
first one being a hundred pixels wide
the second being auto and the third is
set 200 pixels as well so this grid is
responsive as the second column grows
and shrinks with the width of the
container we also have two rows which
are fifty pixels each now the first
thing we're going to do is change the
responsiveness of the grid because let's
say that we want all three columns to
grow in size as the container grows in
size we want them to be equal regardless
of the width in order to achieve that
I'm gonna teach you a new value which
CSS grid brings with it it's called
fraction unit and it's written like this
one Fr let's set all three columns to be
one fraction unit each run fr for the
second one and for the third one and now
as you can see they all grow and shrink
equally so what happens here is that the
grid splits the entire width into three
fractions each of the columns take up
one fraction unit so if we change the
second one here to true fraction unikz
you can see that it'll always be twice
as wide as the first and third column
because now the grid has split the
entire width into four fraction units
and the second one takes up two of those
while the first and third column take up
one each okay so let's go back to having
each of the columns equally wide in this
case we can actually write this in a
simpler way we could do repeat times 1
fraction units as you can see gives the
exact same result so the first parameter
of the repeat function is the amount of
rows or columns and the second one is
the value just the
height or the width of the rows or
columns so let's say we want six columns
instead then we can simply change this
number here to six instead and as you
can see now our six items fill up only
one row as we have six columns and six
items in this grid so let's go back to
three we can also do the same with the
rows of course it's 2 times 50 pixels
finally I also want to show you a
simpler way of defining the rows and
columns because we can use the shorthand
method for this so I'm going to copy the
rows value here and remove that line and
also remove the - columns I'm gonna
paste in neat rows value or just lash
and then let me column value I'm after
that and that'll give the exact same
result so grid template is the shorthand
method for grid template columns and
grid template rows and it can be a bit
hard to remember which one of rows or
columns goes first and which one goes
last and the rule I use to remember this
is to think of it as drawing an L you
start at the top and go downwards across
the rows and then you go to the right
across the columns start with the rows
and then the columns so in the next
screencast you're going to learn how to
adjust the size and position of the
items in the grid so stay tuned and I'll
see you there
Hey in this screencast you're going to
learn how to adjust the position and
size of the items on the grid which is
critical to know in order to create
real-world websites with CSS grid we're
going to create a mock-up for a website
and here in the index.html
you can see the mark-up for that as you
can see we're targeting each of the
items using a class name header menu
content and footer to start with we have
this 2x2 grid each of the columns are
one fraction unit so they're responsive
as you can see and each of the rows are
40 pixels tall for our website though
we're going to need three rows as we
want the header to take up the top row
the menu in the content to being on the
second row and the footer to be on the
third row all the way at the bottom so
let's create a third row here let's
place it in between the two existing
rows and give it a height of 200 pixels
as you can see now the header and the
menu is on the top row on the content
and the footer in the second row and our
third row is blank as we haven't filled
it with content yet since our items only
take up the first four grid cells so
let's change that
we'll start by targeting the header and
making it span from the left hand side
all the way over to the far right-hand
side to achieve that we need to head
into the dot header and give it a grid
column art set that one and also give it
a grid column and at 3 as you can see
now the header spans across the entire
first row and what we're saying here is
that we want the header to start at the
first column line and end at the 3rd
column line and you might wonder why we
have three column lines when we only
have defined two columns well that's
because the first column line goes from
top to bottom on the left side of the
grid the second column line is the one
that separates the two columns and the
third is the one that goes from top to
bottom on the far right hand side of the
grid so when you have two columns you
have three column lines and you can
write that
like this alternatively though we can
also use the shorthand method which I
prefer let's remove this line here and
also remove - start rather do one
forward slash three as you can see that
give us the exact same result
let's also do the exact same thing with
the footer
but now the footer also spans across the
entire width
well critically we could have written
this in a different way we could have
done we could have done one /span - I
don't give the exact same result what
we're saying is that we want the footer
to start at the first column line and
span across two columns and finally
there's also a third way which is to
write minus one that'll target the very
last column line now that we know that
we want our footer and header to span
all the way to the last column line we
can do that with both of them and take
the advantage of the fact that in the
future we might not know how many
columns we're going to have in this grid
as we can change that however we want so
this is a nice little trick when you
don't know exactly how many columns the
item will span across in the grid and to
prove that point view I'm actually going
to change the amount of columns we have
in the grid right now because we don't
want the menu here and the content to
take up an equal amount of space in the
width that doesn't make sense we want
the menu to be a narrow sidebar on the
left-hand side here and we want the
content take up much more space and we
could do this without adding more
columns by simply doing one fr for fr
for example now you can see that the
content takes up much more space since
the second column is for fraction units
and the first column is only one
fraction unit however this is not a very
flexible way of doing it because now
we're still stuck with two columns on a
website layout and you normally want a
lot more columns than that in order to
have the flexibility to shuffle around
and change the content so what I'm going
to do instead is use repeats give it
twelve columns each of one fraction
units now the menu and the content
take up one fraction unit each in other
words one column each and they're
actually forcing the columns to be as
wide as they need in order to display
their content or just the descriptions
we've added inside the items in order to
make this look nice again I'm gonna head
into the content class and give it a
grid column we know that it starts on
the second column line two and we wanted
to go all the way the final column line
like that so we're gonna do minus one
now we have a twelve column layouts
instead of a two column layout meaning
that we have much more flexibility if
you want to shuffle around on stuff and
notice that the footer and the header
still spans across the entire width
which is solely because we're using the
minus one here if we had stuck with the
three here and here that wouldn't work
at all so let's change it back to minus
one now let's also look at the grid row
property as we're going to need that if
we for example want the menu here to
span all the way to the top in order to
do that we first have to change the
header though as we need to make the
space here available this little grid
cell here needs to be available for
ravit mini so we'll change it to two now
we have a blank cell here meaning that
we can head into the menu class and give
it a grid row and set back 1/3 meaning
that it spans from the first row line to
the third row line as you can see took
up the spot here in the top left corner
because this is the first row line this
is the second and here is the third the
fourth then is of course the the bottom
line okay so before we jump onto the
next screencast I would recommend you to
for example try to make the menu span
all the way to the bottom or
alternatively make a pair on the right
hand side instead of on the left hand
side and then in the next screencast I'm
going to show you a really cool way of
defining layouts which gives you a lot
of flexibility in terms of shuffling
around on the content and experimenting
so stay tuned and I'll see you there
Hey in this screencast you're going to
learn really cool feature of CSS grid
called template areas which allows you
to change an experiment with layouts
much more easily than with the
techniques you learned in the previous
cost this feature is ideal for creating
prototypes of the Alps quickly we're
using more or less the same example from
the previous screencast our grid has 12
columns and 3 rows the columns are just
as they were in the previous screencast
however for the rows I've changed the
second one from 200 pixels to Ottawa
that means it'll take up whatever
available space there is left in the
height and combining that with setting
the height of the grid container itself
to a hundred percent this will result in
the grid being responsive in the height
as well
as you can see if we make it taller the
second row grows with the grid now we're
still using the grid column property to
adjust the position and size of the
items what we rather want to do in this
screencast is used something called grid
area and to be able to do that we're
going to have to give the container grid
template areas properly and the syntax
you're about to see now might seem a bit
weird it'll be a visual representation
of the grid and the way it works is that
we'll create a string for each of the
rows and in those strings we'll create a
cell for each of the columns so let's
add letter H 12 times in the first
string we have to give it exactly 12
characters it has to match the amount of
columns so we're not actually defining
the columns or rows here we've already
done that up here we're just naming them
so that we can refer them using these
names later on in the second row Ladd 1m
and elevenses
I thought in the third row rad twelve
F's what you have here is a visual
representation of how we want our grid
to look like unless you might have
understood the age M C and F refer to
header menu content and footer so now
let's remove the old way of positioning
the items like that and build up the
grid over again we'll give the header a
grid area of H as you can see as a
result the header takes up the entire
top row just ass we've defined here
we'll give the menu
grid area M content grid area C footer
grid area of F as you can see our layout
is just the way we want it to be and
it's responsive now the reason this
technique is brilliant for creating
mock-ups is because now I want to make
the menu span all the way to the top
like we did in the previous screencast
we can just replace this edge here with
an M and as you can see automatically
the menu popped up to the top if you
want to make it span all the way to the
bottom let's do the same thing here as
well and just as easy as that
we have changed layouts without having
to fiddle around with the values in the
item classes you can also use dots which
will result in blank cells like that
there there there now we have this weird
experimental layout where all the
corners are blank
now one thing you need to be aware of is
that the areas will only be valid
they are rectangled try and manage this
to an F so that the F footer goes like
that and then up you can see it breaks
the entire layout so you have to use
rectangles as you understand this
a super simple way of experimenting with
the layout so I'd recommend you to play
around with these values here so that
you make sure that you properly
understand it and once you've done that
you have finished the first section of
this course so congratulations you now
know quite a lot about CNS Grid however
there's still a lot of stuff to learn so
in the next section I'm gonna teach you
some more advanced stuff and we're gonna
create even more responsive grids
that'll be super cool so I'll see you
there
heyyyyyy and welcome to the second
section in this CSS grid course in it
you're going to learn more advanced
concepts you've already learned about
responsiveness but now we're going to
take that to a new level so here we have
the setup for a grid which you can see
in the browser window as well it's got
six columns and two rows and that's
defined here and should be pretty basic
to you by now both the columns and rows
have a value of a hundred pixels in
width and Heights
so this grid is not responsive now as
you can see but we know from previous
costs we can turn it into responsive
grid by doing 1fr instead now the
columns will grow and shrink with the
width of the container
however you wouldn't necessarily always
want your columns to be six like now
they're very squeezed together and at
this point they're suddenly very wide
what you perhaps rather room to do is
for example only have two in width when
the example is being viewed on a mobile
and six in width when it's viewed on a
normal screen so let's make the amount
of columns vary with the width of the
container will first go back to having
100 pixels here instead and then rather
than hard coding in six columns we're
going to use something called auto it
now what will happen is that it'll vary
the amount of columns with the width of
the grid as you can see it simply tries
to fit as many columns as possible into
the container and when it gets a hundred
pixels extra space on the right hand
side it'll boom add a new one so on a
very narrow screen it'll only show a
couple of columns however this doesn't
give us the responsiveness ramones
as the amount of hundred pixel columns
rarely add up exactly to the width of
the container then we get a situation
like this here where we have quite a lot
of space left on the right hand side
though not enough to add a new column
and that doesn't look nice now you might
think that we could rather do auto fit
1fr however that'll only give us one
column because auto fit tries to fill up
the grid with as many columns as
possible until there's not enough space
to add a new column so when you use
for action unit it starts by adding one
column however then all with is used up
immediately because at that point both
the width of the entire container and
the first column are set to one fraction
unit so to get the behavior we want
we're going to use something called min
Max and we'll set our columns to be
minimum or hundred pixels maximum one
fraction unit now you'll see that the
columns will always fit the entire grid
regardless of whether or not the
container exactly adds up to 100 pixels
so what happens here is that the columns
will always be at least 100 pixels but
if there's more available space it'll
simply distribute that equally across
all the columns so now there are more or
less hundred pixels if we make the page
a little bit wider you can see that it
stretches all of the columns so now the
width of the container is something like
550 pixels or something
however when it reaches 600 pixels there
it uses the minimum size for the columns
so that it can fit in six columns so it
prefers to use the minimum however when
it doesn't add up to exactly 500 or 600
pixels it uses one fraction unit instead
so now we also get a nice view on mobile
like that and a nice view on a very wide
screen okay so in the next screencast
I'm going to tell you about implicit
rows so stay tuned and I'll see you
there
heyyyyyy in this screencast we're going
to continue with grid from the previous
one as it still has an issue we need to
fix because if we make this grid narrow
like this and have a look at the rows
that are created beneath the two rows
redefined we'll see that they're not
acting the way we want them to they're
not a hundred pixels in height which we
define here they're only as tall as the
content inside of them force them to be
and that's because they are implicitly
created because as you can see here we
only explicitly created two rows however
with our current defined behavior for
the columns we are going to need
somewhere to place these items which
can't fit in our explicit grid up here
so from five and onwards we need to
create new rows automatically in order
to display our items and as we haven't
told our grid how we want to style rows
that it has to add to the grid itself it
just has to decide for itself how these
rows are going to look so let's fix this
because we can target these rows by
simply doing grid Auto rows and set the
value to a hundred pixels and now as you
can see the just how we want them to be
you can see that as well
grows and shrinks nicely with all rows
always being unheard pixels tall and now
that we've defined this one we can
actually get rid of this one like that
now all rows will be created implicitly
and they'll always be under pixels tall
so in the next screencast we're going to
tie all the concepts you've learned up
until now together and create a super
cool image grid so I'm looking forward
to see you there
hey and welcome to the final screencast
of the second section here we're going
to take what you've learned up until now
and use it to create really cool image
grid I've already created the setup
we're using the technique for
responsiveness which we talked about
previously using autofit in combination
with min/max which gives us a nice
responsive grid that varies the amount
of columns and the rows are implicitly
created and are 75 pixels tall in the
index.html you can see that I've added
an image to each of the items in the
grid that's of course the images you can
see here and this is already I'd say a
pretty cool grid however not all of
these images fit the frame they're given
equally well some of them might be more
horizontal while other images might be
more vertical I also have a few
favorites which I think deserve a little
bit of extra attention you can see
they're actually given some of these
item classes like vertical horizontal
and big these are the images which I
don't think fit well into only one grid
cell so let's go ahead and make the
horizontal images twice as wide head
over to the CSS to the horizontal class
and we'll set the grid column property
now previously we'd do something like
one that's the starting value and then
example to span two so that they'd span
across two columns however as you can
see that'll force all the horizontal
images which is this one this one for
example to start in the first column
line if we enlarge in the grid you'll
see that they'll but they'll still stick
to the first grid column line which
amongst other things leaves open spaces
in the grid to something we're going to
talk about later on so what we rather
want to do is swap out this one here
with Auto now you can see they start on
whatever column line they were given
initially this one starts here and these
two now happen to start on the first
column line but if we change the way
they could you can see that the
horizontal images start on various grid
lines
just one what we actually also can do
here is remove this entirely and just do
grid column span too so the grid column
and grid row properties can take a lot
of different values and combinations and
at this point this is the simplest we
can do however I wanted to show you the
various alternatives okay now let's do
the same thing with the vertical images
the ones we want to make taller than the
rest of the images so here will use grid
row and set back to span two as you can
see this one and this one
they're now taller than all the others
now we've gotten a few blank cells
throughout the grid and we're going to
talk about that in a minute
whoever it let's first make the big
images once we want to highlight twice
as tall and twice as wide as we in
normal images grid column and two and
grid row span now you can see this image
here and this one here and this one here
are really getting the attention they
deserve but we need to fix these blank
spots here because that doesn't look
nice so why do these blank spots appear
to understand that let's look at how the
grid lays out each of the items starts
up here in the top left corner lays out
the first item 2nd 3rd 4th 5th and then
it needs to continue on the next row
which is here and it tries to fit in the
6th image however when it's about to lay
out that one it can't fit it as it only
has one grid cell available here however
the sixth item is a big one it's this
one here let's double check that in the
HTML one two three four five six and
that is indeed the big item
so what it then does is that it
continues on looking at the next cell
that's already taken so it jumps onto
the next cell again and here it actually
has enough space to lay out the big item
and then it simply continues laying out
the next item here here and then one
here leaving that spot here blank
wouldn't be great if we somehow could
fill these parts well we can and to do
that we're going to use a property
called grid Auto flow X by default set
to row meaning that it'll lay out the
items one row at a time just as we
talked about starting here and going
across the first row and then jumping
next to the second row and continuing on
like that however if we set it to dense
blues so-called dense packing algorithm
which attempts to fill the holes in the
grid if there are holes in the grid and
smaller items come up later then it'll
move those up to fill the blank spaces
so if we go back to row we see that this
space is blank
the next item in the grid which could
potentially fit in here would be not
this one the sixth item but the seventh
item of the waterfall here so let's look
at what happens when you change it to
dense and indeed the waterfall image has
now jumped back to this position and
filled that hole and this works
regardless of how wide the screen is as
you can see we have a super cool image
grid now which looks really hard to
create actually however we've done it
simply using these 20 lines of CSS and
finally I want to mention that this
dense feature here is an example of
sorts order independence which is a huge
win for CSS it means that the grid can
arrange the items regardless of how
they're laid out in the arc up here we
simply use the mark-up for what it's
supposed to use for markup for content
and we're using the CSS for what it's
supposed to be used for styling and
we're not limited to whatever order we
laid out the images initially
so source order independence gives you a
lot of flexibility so this marks the end
of this section you now know quite a lot
about building advanced CSS grid layouts
however be sure to check out the bonus
material if you're hungry to learn even
more thank you
heyyyyyy in this screencast you're going
to learn a new way of positioning and
sizing the items on the grid using
something called named lines so we've
defined our normal grid here which is
the website layout you should be
familiar with by now though in this case
we're defining it in the very simple way
of only having two columns one being one
fraction unit and one being five
fraction units so we're not using the
flexible twelve column layout here as
this set up makes it easier when you
sing named lines so to brush up a little
bit the grid has column lines and row
lines and the first column line is the
one on the left hand side second one is
one separating in the two columns and
the third one is the one on the far
right hand side and our content item for
example is defined to span from the
second row line to the third row line
from here to here in our code that will
be from the line that goes in between
here and until the line that goes here
so what we now can do is we can add a
square bracket in between and write
confident start for example on the third
line write confident and like that now
what we can do is we can swap out the
number two here with content start and
the number three with Uncle end like
that as you can see that works fine if
we wanted to do the same thing for the
header we'd have to give a name to the
first line as well up here let's call
that main start now the header spans
from main start to content end however I
actually want to call this line main end
as well
because there might be a case in the
future where we're going to reference
the main end explicitly not use content
end as a proxy for it so so let's just
add a new name here paint and like that
just give it a space and then the new
name
now we can do main art mein and as you
can see works perfectly fine the footer
can get the exact same layout like that
now let's also name the rows using the
exact same convention will you main
start I'm just going to copy them I'm
going to start end and main end like
that now you might wonder why we've been
using this - syntax here and that's
because they give you a little bit of
magic
now given that we've called this line
here for content start and this line
here for content end the grid knows that
this is the content column or columns if
that was the case so you can actually
set the grid column to just content like
that and as you can see it works now the
header and the footer spans from main
start to main and so we can do the exact
same thing there as well just use grid
column main and to take this even a step
further actually we can also use grid
area in one of these cases that'll be in
the content case because let's have a
look at the content lines both the row
lines and the column lines so we know we
have the content start here and the
content and here though we also have a
Content start here the second row line
first second so this one here and we
have a content end on the third row line
the third one here meaning we have boxed
in an area with content lines here here
here here and here and now we can
actually use grid area which you
you might remember from section 1 of
this course by simply doing grid area
and set it to continent like that and it
still works however you might be tempted
to try and do the same thing down on the
footer though that wouldn't work because
it has to be boxed in by four main lines
though the main start row line is the
one that starts up here not down here
above the footer so here we have only
kind of boxed it partially in we have
the main start column line here which is
the start of the footer and the main end
row line just the bottom of the footer
and the main end column line which is
the right hand side of the footer though
the top of the footer is the content and
line so we can't use grid area main here
as you can see it breaks the entire
layout so be careful and make sure that
you have properly boxed in an area
before you start using grid area okay
now sit for this bonus screencast thank
you
Hey in this screencast I'm going to show
you how to justify and align the entire
content of a grid I've added here a
black border around the grid container
so that we can see its edges we've also
made sure that the grid is fully
responsive and that there's a little bit
of space around it so right now our grid
items only occupy a tiny part of the
entire grid container and that's
important in order to learn about the
justifying and aligning the content so
let's start with the justification which
defines and distributes space between
and around the items along the row axis
from left to right so if we set justify
content and set that to end as you can
see that'll shuffle all the content over
to the right-hand side to the end of
that axis the row axis the default value
here was start we also do Center like
that now Center it along the row axis so
let's combine this with a line content
as well and do you think for example
I'll push all the content down to the
lower end of the grid because aligning
controls the content along the column
axis the vertical one which goes from
top to bottom if we do Center hair as
well will fully Center the items in the
grid
now let's comment out this one and and
have a look at the other values you can
use here as there's a couple of cool
ones if we for example want a lot of
space in between the items we can do
space clean now we have a smart
space as possible in between the items
along the row axis you can also do space
evenly like that which distributes the
items evenly throughout the row axis so
the items have an equal amount of space
around them
finally there's also the space round
this one is pretty similar to space
evenly though each of the items have a
half size space on either end meaning
that if you have two items besides each
other
that'll give a full size space between
them though here in between the first
column line and the first item you only
have a half space as this item forces a
half space on this side though the grid
line itself doesn't force the grid to
create any space for it though in
between these two both of the items
first the grid to add a half space in
between them resulting resulting in full
size space so that was the basics of
justifying and aligning the content
thank you
Hey in this screencast I'll teach you
how to justify and align the items on
the grid so here we have our classic
website layout it contains 12 columns in
the width each are one fraction unit and
three rows where the second one is auto
so this grid is responsive in both width
and height as you can see we have
defined the width of each of the items
using the grid column value so from the
header for example we're saying start at
the first column line which is this one
and end at the last one which is this
one over on the right hand side so it's
kind of stretching from the start point
to the end point and this axis here the
row axis is the one you control with
justification so if we do or if we do
buy items that'll be by defaults that
good stretch however if we for example
want each of the items to rather Center
itself as much as possible and not
stretch all the way from the left-hand
side to the right-hand side we can use
center as you can see now each of the
items are centered at as much as
possible you can also use spart that'll
squeeze all of them towards the
left-hand side and end is the opposite
of this that'll squeeze all the items to
the right-hand side
now let's comment out this a little bit
and use the line items property that'll
do the same thing though along the
column axis so the vertical axis from
top to bottom if we do Center here you
can see that each of the items are now
squeezed together towards the center
though not only left to right row axis
but on the top to bottom column axis we
can do and that'll squeeze all them to
the bottom or start that'll squeeze them
towards the top now let's do the center
again and combine this with center here
now all the items just a tiny rectangle
in the center of the grid cells which
had originally occupied fulling
now I have no idea why I would want to
create a website layout like this it's
really weird but that's besides the
point of this screencast finally let's
finally let's comment out these few get
back to the original layout and look at
how you can do the same thing though
only targeting one of the items let's
head into the content for example then
you can use justify itself a new center
now only the content is centered aligned
office well and and now the content is
squeezed down to this tiny little box in
the bottom center of the huge space it
originally occupied a little bit sad
actually to see the content to see the
content being turned into a shadow of
itself like that so let's give it back
its original space like that okay so
that's it I hope you learned something
and feel free to play around with this
yourself thank you
heyy in this screencast I'm going to
explain the difference between autofit
and autofit so here we have two
different grids using one or the other
you can see them on the page here and
I'm assuming that you understand the
basics of this complicated expression
here we're basically repeating with
autofit as many columns as we can fit
into the grid given these constraints
here they should be minimum 100 pixels
and maximum one fraction unit that as
you probably remember from the
screencast in the second section will
give a nice responsive behavior where
the amount of columns grows with the
size of the grid like this if we enlarge
in this page boom there the grid crossed
the 300 pixel threshold meaning it could
fit three columns in instead of two and
as we make it more wide the columns
become one fraction unit until it
reaches the next threshold which is 400
pixels and boom then autofit and autofit
adds another column to the grid since we
now can fit 400 pixel columns into the
grid however there's a slight difference
between the two and that'll be apparent
if we try to enlarge the grid even more
like this now what you can see and that
autofill actually added fifth column
even though we don't have a fifth
element to add there where is auto fit
made sure that the four items we have
actually fit the grid now under the hood
what's happening here is actually that
both of them add new column tracks
though auto fit actually collapses those
new columns to see row pixels in width
so that the current items you have in
the grid when defined like this with a
maximum size of one fraction unit
actually will fit to the grid regardless
where's autofill at every 100 threshold
right there and there and there it'll
add new column tracks which basically
are empty so that was the difference
between autofit and autofit
in this example I will show you how we
can use CSS grids to create an article
layout so in this example I have a plain
article that I've written
I wrote it originally in markdown and
then I generated this HTML using a
markdown compiler so it's not so it's
pretty nice it has you else it had
Soapy's there's a div here for the code
highlighting and a figure a figure tag
for the image and just basic HTML and
I'm just going to go straight ahead and
turn this into grid and then I will
explain what I'm trying to accomplish
that so how it looks now we have a grid
which is very funky move everything
where I want it I'm gonna come to me and
there we go so now I've defined the grid
which has three columns there's the
first column that's 80 pixels then
there's a main column that takes one
fraction of the space and then there's
the right column that takes 80 pixels
and I have this rule here which says
that every element inside article should
start at the grid column line number two
so remember that the grade column line
one goes down here two goes down here
then we have three over here and four
over there and by setting grid com2 we
say that everyone should start in this
column and we need to set the min width
to zero to actually allow it to shrink
if we don't set this you will see that
it goes all the way over there oh right
now this is just a way of adding some
spaces on the side but since this is
Grint we can now glue some things very
easily since I now want this figure take
the whole width
and that was wrong and let's add some
space on top of it right so what did we
do here
I set the grid column to start at line
one and end at line -1 which is the last
one so this is the way I was saying make
the element take the whole width and
this is just radically simple them and
the other way to accomplish the same
thing if you don't have a CSS grid you
end up having to say that these elements
here should have a margin and standard
margin and this should not you know then
cancel out the margin you set by default
and often this is very tricky because
you often end up having to have custom
HTML just to handle where things should
when there should be narrow and when it
should be white and it's can be really
tricky deciding where to put things
so another thing that we can do is to
add another element I'm going to call it
aside and here I'm going to just write
some text now we have this new paragraph
over here and now I can style it now I
want to style it like this I want to say
in the third column I want to have a
gray color smaller font size
this seems like a good time to add
spacing
so yeah and if I wanted to be on the
left side I think I said they look
really calm two three one and trust me
if you're trying to do this without a
width it's it's so hacky I can't even
begin to think like because you have
this element here which originally has
some margin and then maybe if you put
both of these elements inside the same
deal maybe you can do like
position:absolute and set left a hundred
percent or something yeah I don't know I
don't really know this is just something
I don't know a clean way of doing in
plain CSS and especially not in a way
where you can have no changes in the
HTML basically now there is one thing
you need to know and that is this is
actually a separate grid so this is
becoming a grid row that goes here and
this is separate grid row and this has
the consequence that you often end up
with this spaces you might in this case
want this space to be gone and then this
text to go down further to the right
side or the other but that's currently
not possible
with CSS quit that's just limitation
that you can't really avoid and whether
it's good or bad
I don't really know in this case I don't
think it's that bad because this
paragraph belongs with this paragraph
and here we have a header which starts a
completely new section so it's not that
big a problem but if we had like another
paragraph over here it can be a bit
confusing that you have these big spaces
which isn't quite optimal but other than
that I find that using CSS grid for this
type of article out makes the the HTML
much cleaner you can basically just take
the output from a markdown parser and
dump it straight in you don't need to do
anything special to support either
having things in the left column or the
right column or in in full width
and the styling itself it's 20 lines and
even here I haven't touched anything
like block quotes both here's the
clothes maybe you also want that to be
in the full width oh we should remove
much another side that maybe we want to
separate color once again and maybe like
order left school solid thing as well
and notice that i can just add padding
and borders i just set the column to be
from 1 to minus 1 and everything works i
don't need to worry about negative
margins or or knowing what the wind of
this columnist so now if i want to start
the left column 317 third or maybe 40
and the right come to be 40 that works
perfectly fine
and all is just very very good thanks
Hey in this screencast I'm going to talk
about the difference between flexbox and
grid and I'm also going to show you how
you can use the two together so we have
a header here which is built using
flexbox
and a page layout which is built using
CSS grid here is the HTML for the grid
example and the HTML for the Flex box
example and the CSS is located in the
index dot CSS file here and we're going
to look at this code in a minute however
let's first look at the examples
themselves cuz you might actually be
able to guess the main difference
between flexbox and grid just by looking
at these two examples because flexbox
is built for one dimensional layout like
this one goes in one direction from left
to right being just a single row whereas
CSS grid is built for two-dimensional
layouts like this page here it has three
rows the top one the middle one and the
bottom one that actually has 12 columns
though we can only see two of them
visually here due to how we've laid out
the items so if you're going to create
layout which has a direction either row
or column then use flexbox it's great
for lining content within that container
and gives you a lot of flexibility
however if we're going to create a more
overall layout with both rows and
columns then you should definitely use
CSS grid as it'll give you much more
flexibility and simpler markup than if
you worked for example try to use
flexbox
to create two-dimensional layouts okay
there's also another overall difference
which is that flexbox
take spaces in the content it's so
called content first
whereas grid its layout first it takes
spaces in the layout now this might seem
a little bit abstract so let's look into
the cold as that'll make it a bit more
clear
so the flexbox header here is turning to
a flexible box by simply giving it a
display flex you don't have to do
anything else we then let the content
make most of the decisions of where
they're going to be placed throughout
the container for example you can see
the third child here the logout element
simply adds a margin to its left-hand
side and thereby shoving itself all the
way to the end
the container now let's look at how we
create our grid layout first of all we
can't just simply give it a display grid
and then start shoving content into the
container no we also have to define
either columns or rows or both as we're
doing here
we're giving it 12 columns each being a
fraction unit wide and three rows and
just by doing this you can understand
that grid in your larger degree takes
basis in the layout first you're
constrained by the layout you define
here whereas we could have added as many
items in the width on this single row in
our header here you now constrained with
12 columns in our grid example here and
also we need to place the elements
according to the layout for example this
menu item here this one which you can
see on the left hand side here we're not
placing it here by giving it a margin on
its right-hand side like we do on the
logout we're taking bases in the layout
and saying that we wanted to span from
the first column line to the second
column line and thereby it places itself
how we want this layout first versus
content first it's a bit abstract and
it's not something you think about when
you develop though it's nice to be aware
of it so finally let's actually combine
the two because that's what you want to
do you want to combine CSS grid with a
flexbox and then get the best of both
worlds so now what we're going to do
we're going to take this header here
move it down into our H layout so let's
head over to the HTML and take the three
elements here copy them and add them
here like that that's what we now we'll
do is we'll turn the header here into a
flexbox
giving it a display on flex alex run
this code as you can see we have the
items laid out like this what we now can
do we can use for example justify
conflict do for example space evenly
like that as you can see they change
accordingly
wherever let's do what we did in the
flexbox layout
target the third child logout button
margin-left:auto as easy as that you've
combined CSS grid with flexbox now this
header here this item in the grid
container is actually a Flex container
itself which then again has three items
within itself so I hope you learned
something from this and that you'll
start using grid and flex box together
from now on
thank you